Charter schooling introduced many
important innovations. It showed how we
could have school choice inside of
public education; how nonprofits could
run public schools; how great public
schools can be replicated or expanded.
But we've never made full use of one of
the charter schooling's most important
contributions: contract-based
accountability. A charter school
negotiates performance contracts with an
authorizer. That contract lays out
exactly what the school will accomplish.
In exchange, the school then gets
freedom from a wide array of rules.
Now, if the charter school succeeds, its
contract will be renewed. But if it fails
to meet its performance goals, the school
will be closed and replaced. The new
federal education law encourages states
to create accountability systems
that are new.
So why not apply contract-based
accountability to all public schools in
a city, including those run by the
traditional school district? This is the
way for all of the city's schools -
charter schools and district schools - to
have equal operational freedom and be
held equally accountable.
To learn more about my take on charter school
accountability, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you want AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.